after a sweet debut in Jessica Jones
Mike Coulter's Luke Cage powers back
onto Netflix with his very own series
and just like daredevil and Jessica
Jones before him Luke Cage his show is
bursting with Easter eggs cameos and
references to everything from Star Wars
to Iron Fist
Deadpool and a stack of comic books so
I've put together as many of those
Easter eggs and callbacks as I could in
this video do let me know what other
cool ones you spotted and just a quick
reminder of course they're asked boilers
ahead Luke Cage first appeared an issue
one of Hero for Hire the title of which
describes how his character operated and
is one of his aliases so it's not
surprising that there are several nods
to that in the Netflix show after Luke
saves Genghis Khan ease from
cottonmouths men Connie says she wants
to hire Luke however in contrast to the
comics Luke says he's not for hire but
he will look out for her and when Luke
tells fish I ain't no hero during their
conversation in the diner and fish
replies that's a great slogan I ain't no
hero pay me that's a nice reference to
the fact that in the comics Luke's
heroic activities were available for a
fee Method Man also gives a shout-out to
Luke's Hero for Hire alias in his rap
bulletproof love from issue 17 the Hero
for Hire comic book series was titled
Power Man when Luke decided he needed a
better name and there are a number of
hints to his Power Man moniker in the
show pop jokingly calls Luke Power Man
on a couple of occasions and when Claire
temple caused Luke Macho Man only to be
corrected by Luke who says his name is
Power Man
she laughed at that's even cornea and
there's a nod to the Ace of Spades alias
which Luke rejected in the comics when
Luke's told to take up 6 bottles of Ace
of Spades to the clubs the IP area
during the first episode the silver
metal head gear and gauntlets we see
Luke wearing following dr. Burton's
experiments is a callback to the
characters original comic book costume
which he donned for many years following
his first appearance in 1972 and Luke's
comic book head gear gets another
mention later in the show when Luke and
Claire temple discover a file on Rivas
hip drive with a title tiara
by the way tiara was also the production
code name for the Netflix series Luke's
traditional comic book look also
included a partially open yellow shirt
blue trousers and a chain belt all of
which make an appearance in the show
when he grabbed the yellow shirt
a pair of blue jeans for a washing line
after his escape from prison when Luke
catches sight of his reflection and
comments that his new clothes make him
look like a damn fool
it's a nice reference to the fact that
in the comics he also felt his superhero
outfit was kind of hokey and just as
Luke drops of seventies style clothes
for more 21st century appropriate attire
in the show after that his comic book
character destroyed his traditional
costume in 1992 on the cover of the
first issue of the new series cage and
the t-shirts jeans and casual jackets
that Luke worth throughout the show
reflect his more modern look in the
comic books in the 1990s onwards Luke's
hoodie is a nod to seventeen-year-old
Trayvon Martin he was shot dead by
George Zimmerman in Florida in 2012 and
showrunner Jo Coker has said that it was
important to him as the father of two
black sons to have a black man in a
hoodie and have them not be a threat the
color of Luke's hoodie references his
comic book costumes from his early days
through to more contemporary times as
does a blue tracksuit and yellow bandage
worn by the young con Lucas training in
a boxing gym during a flashback scene
and Luke's red t-shirts in the show is a
callback to the 90s cage comics where
Luke dropped his previous yellow outfit
for red the incident aka the Battle of
New York and the Avengers gets a number
of mentions in the show for example
there's a lad selling war footage of the
incident on DVD which he says features
Tony Stark the big blond dude with the
hammer the old dude with the shield and
the Green Monster in other words Thor
Captain America and the Hulk
then there's Claire temple's mother who
talks about the way the world's changed
with aliens coming out of the sky people
with silver hammers and green monsters
again referring to Thor in the Hulk as
well as such a Towery invasion after
being explored most recently in Captain
America Civil War as well as Daredevil
and Jessica Jones the MCU is continuing
big debate about where the superheroes
are a good thing to be supported whether
their powers should be controlled crops
that repeatedly in Luke Cage early on in
the show misty Knight and her partner
Skaar fur on opposite sides of the issue
scarf who says he saw the incident up
close and what cops can and can't do is
happy for people like Kage to clean up
the streets while misty believes it's
Anarchy and that superheroes have no
responsibility or training Iron Man 2
villain Justin Hammer
to be still in business as we see hammer
industries weapons being sold by cotton
mouth and the Judas bullet that
diamondback uses against Luke is said to
be based on a prototype by hammer and is
made from alien metal from the incident
interestingly in the Marvel one-shot all
hail the king
we discovered that Justin Hammer was
incarcerated in Seagate prison just as
Luke Cage of being which also links to
Reavers comment in the show about
million earth hidden in dungeons at
Seagate when misty Knight injures her
arm during the hostage siege at Harlem's
Paradise it's a nod to the bionic arm
that Tony Stark gave her in the comics
after she lost her own arm during a bomb
attack Misty's her style and the red
dress she's wearing in the last shot we
see Aran in the final episode is a
reference to a classic red costume and
look in the comics
Simone misuk has confirmed that misty
Knight is returning for the defenders so
the show could be hinting that we might
see her suited up next time and with a
possible super-powered arm the Biggie
Smalls port traits by Baron Claiborne
that hangs on cottonmouths wall is a nod
to Luke Cage showrunner Jo Coker who
wrote a biography of the notorious b.i.g
and he also co-wrote his biopic
notorious and in the show's second
episode Faith Evans whose Biggie's Widow
also performs the song mesmerised at
Harlem's paradise during the discussion
that Mariah and Cornell have in front of
the portrays Marvel opted against giving
Cornell cottonmouth Stokes a sharp
fang-like teeth his character has in the
comics however there's a hint at that
when pop talks about how cottonmouth
lost three T's as a child the show's
costume designer Stephanie muslin skee
said she wanted to reflect cottonmouth
snake like green colors from the comics
which is why she had Maher Schiller Ali
were what she calls a fantastic fly
looking green suit the first time we see
Cornel Stokes on screen when Luke calls
Diamondback a snake it's a nod to the
villain snake skin like costume from the
comics and in the show Diamondbacks
hammer tech costume does resemble the
characters comic book costume except for
the helmet when diamondback reveals his
true relationship to Luke with the words
I am your brother it calls to mind Darth
Vader's I am your father reveal to Luke
Skywalker in the Empire Strikes Back
Star Wars gets another couple of
references with pop talking about Jedi
Mind Tricks and fish calling Diamondback
a pimp stormtrooper when he arrives at a
bar
shop in his hammer tech suit and the
show continues the tradition of Marvel's
face to Amash to Star Wars limb loss
with Mabel Stokes severing the finger of
a young lad who's selling drugs although
Willis Stryker aka Diamondback and Carl
Lucas were never brothers in the comics
they were friends in both the show in
the comics Willis was jealous of Carl
and framed him for a crime he didn't
commit which led him to seagate prison
however the comics and the TV show
portray Willis's jealousy and Carl's
crime differently still the name of the
Judas bullet which Diamondback uses
against Luke Fitz this whole idea of
betrayal when Diamondback pretends he
was responsible for Eva's death in the
show it's a nod to the comics where he
did accidentally caused her death after
she was caught in mob crossfire that was
targeting Willis there's a sneaky Easter
Egg to timely comics on the dumpster
labeled timely trash behind Diamondback
a misty night in episode 8 timely
trashes logo is similar to that of
timely comics which was founded in 1939
and later became Marvel Comics who's a
name dropped the super villain Black
Maria when Cornell calls his cousin
Mariah Dillard by that name black Mariah
was a Luke Cage enemy in the comics who
later became involved in the drug trade
so the name drop could indicate Dilla's
possible future in the Netflix shows
many of the scenes at Sea Gate rather
faithful to luke cage's origin story is
told in here for high issue 1 the
sadistic and racist prison guard
Albert Rackham who triggered Luke cages
superpowers by deliberately overheating
Luke's experimental chemical bath has a
very similar comic book counterpart
called Billy Bob Rackham in here over
hire Rackham also deliberately tries to
kill Carl Lucas by turning the dial up
on the experiment the way Lucas
discovers his super-strength after
punching the prison wall and the way he
punches through to escape from seagate
is also remarkably close to the comic
book pages from Hero for Hire a poster
behind Reaver for a talk by warden
Stuart is a shout-out to warden Tyler
Stuart from the comics who moved Rackham
down the ranks to a regular guard at Sea
Gate shades also spent time in Sea Gate
with Luke Cage and has a similar story
in the comics later returning to New
York to a life of crime interestingly in
the comics shades also works against
Luke Cage and iron fist but for Ward
Meechum who upgrade shades sunglasses to
an optic blasting
either which is something we could see
in the upcoming Iron Fist show or the
defenders dr. Burstein was also at Sea
Gate conducting experiments on inmates
in both the comics and the show in the
comics he experimented with a version of
the Super Soldier Serum used to create
Captain America and although that's not
stated explicitly in the show there is
an allusion to it when cottonmouths
sarcastically asked new curvy thinks his
harlem's Captain America and when dr.
Burstein later offers Claire temple a
job working with him is a nod to the
time in the comics when Burstein and
Claire worked together at the storefront
clinic in New York and the end of season
kiss between Claire and Luke reflects
the fact that Claire temple was also one
of luke cage's
earliest love interest in the comics
like the previous Netflix Marvel shows
Luke Cage continues to show parallels
between Claire and the comic book
character night nurse for example during
the Harlem's Paradise hostage situation
when Claire fakes having to leave to get
some medicine one of the gods says
escort the night nurse here downstairs
when Luke Cage accidentally destroys a
can of shaving cream after his prison
escape it's a nod to the two-page magic
shave Luke Cage custom comic ad by
Marvel in which Luke accidentally
interrupts a guy who's using magic shave
cream in the ad Luke accidentally
smashes through the bathroom wall during
a fight with the absorbing man and he
quips that he didn't even get scratched
a good excuse for the shaving guy to
explain how he didn't get scratched
either thanks to magic shave we get to
hear Luke Cage say his classic
catchphrase from the comics sweet
Christmas 5 times during the show and we
also hear it from the mouth of a young
Willis striker who tells a young Luke
during boxing training not to give him
that sweet Christmas [ __ ] according to
comic book writer and static shock
created Dwayne McDuffie Luke's
catchphrase owes its existence to the
fact that Luke Cage writer Archie
Goodwin took inspiration from the Harlem
detective novels of author Chester Himes
and actually there's a couple of shout
outs specifically to Chester Himes in
the show both at Pop's barbershop Anwen
Luke is discussing books while being
taken back to prison in the finale
another book that makes an appearance in
the show is Walter Mosley's little green
which we see Luke reading at various
points the hard-boiled detective novel
is part of Mosley as easy warlin series
and has easy waking up after falling
into coma in the previous book and
features the detective search for a
missing young man
parallels luke cage's situation in the
show where he's recovered from being
shot in the head in jessica jones and is
trying to find Chico there's a cool
tease for iron fist in the finale when
Claire takes the number of her flyer
advertising self-defense of martial arts
training by sensei Coley wing honing
wing will be one of Danny rands allies
in the next Netflix Marvel series iron
fist and will be played by Jessica
Henrik and the upcoming defenders series
gets plenty more set up in Luke Cage
with references to Daredevil and Jessica
Jones the other key members of the group
in the finale Claire offers to contact a
really great lawyer she knows
referencing Matt Murdock aka daredevil
and after fish finds some missing files
that can prove Luke's innocence
presumably Matt Murdock will be able to
appeal his sentence Jessica Jones and
how she killed killgrave gets referenced
in Mariah Dillard's speech against
super-powered individuals where she
mentions how that woman over in Hell's
Kitchen snapped a man's neck because he
was mind controlling her and Trish
Walker
Jessica Jones's best friend makes a
little voice cameo in Luke Cage as we
hear her radio show twitch talk
discussing Luke Cage his activities
lawyer who represents cottonmouth and
VIP host death Candice is Ben Donovan
you also acted as Wilson Fisk's lawyer
in season 2 of daredevil his comic book
counterpart is Big Ben Donovan
Harlan based lawyer who first appeared
in 1973 in the Hero for Hire series and
her time in the comics Donovan acted as
a lawyer for both Kage and Claire temple
assistant DA Blake tower from the second
season of daredevil also makes a brief
cameo when he arrives to check on the
hostage situation at Harlan's paradise
while Stan Lee popped up in police
station posters and pictures in
Daredevil and Jessica Jones in Luke Cage
his face features on a poster in a local
store window and right below that poster
there's another one advertising a
nightclub party with the word DJ in big
letters which feels like a little hint
at Stan Lee's cameo as a strip club DJ
or I'm see in the Deadpool movie
Method Man makes a cool cameo in the
store scene with two bumbling robbers he
jokes with Luke Cage who gives a shout
out to his early work and the swap
hoodies Layton Method Man performs his
Luke Cage tribute rap bulletproof love
on the real live radio show sways
universe way in the morning in
Jing Li one of method man's aliases is
Johnny Blaze which is also the name of
one of Marvel's ghost rider characters
who was played on the big screen by
superhero fan Nick Cage who took his
stage surname from Luke Cage his nearest
not in the show to the raised fist
salute that's often associated with the
Black Panther Party and the Black Power
movement
there's Luke's raised fist as it punches
out of the rubble of Genghis Khan ease
in Episode four and the fist Luke makes
while he's being treated in bursts
Dean's tank of boiling acid in Episode
nine by the way black lives matter
also crops up in a speech by Mariah
Dillard the Luke Cage show introduces a
new TV news network wjb PTV
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
features the news report in megamix
Aaron mega McClaren and des baux jbp TV
first appeared in the cinder bolts
comics in 1997 and finally there's a
sneaky easter egg the graphic designer
of Marvel's Netflix shows Zachary
Zeeland whose name appears in a
newspaper headline misty Knight scrolls
past when she's trying to find out who
will it strike it is in the newspaper
archive zealand's designs responsible
for many of the visual Easter eggs
hidden in all of Marvel's Netflix shows
including the New York bulletin
different pages on top of that the
author of the newspaper article Jeff
Coogan is the art department coordinator
on all the Marvel Netflix shows as well
so there are some of my top Easter eggs
references and cameos from Luke Cage but
which were your favorites and what did I
miss
and what do you think about Luke Cage
and how's it compare to Daredevil and
Jessica Jones let me know in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video do hit those like and share
buttons and subscribe if you're not
already if you're a fan of comic book TV
shows you can also check out my Jessica
Jones daredevil and Iron Fist videos
here and also 10 things you probably
didn't know about the flash thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers